it's officially the 90-day mark in less
than three months
you are the ultimate jury and you will
make the most consequential decision
in our lifetime especially for our kids
and grandkids
america the world is literally on the
brink freedom liberty capitalism versus
radical status liberty crushing
socialism
that's what happens in 90 days do you
want joe biden
well the ever confused one bolshevik
bernie aoc
bozo schumer pelosi running the country
well i do not ronald reagan warned
that this nation he warned us all
freedom is but
one generation away from extinction well
we owe it to our kids and grandkids
to not be that generation that lets it
become
extinct and earlier today biden had yet
well another complete public meltdown
while trying to just answer a simple
question
about his cognitive abilities that he
bragged so much about
passing the test and i take them all the
time
that full tape is coming up and we'll
ask important questions
about his fitness for office that the
media mob
they talk about privately democrats talk
about privately
but never publicly also major breaking
news out of the swamp
sally yates was just grilled by the
senate judiciary committee where she
accused
mr higher honor himself of going rogue
and was forced to admit that the fisa
applications that she
signed the ones that say verified were
fraudulent
and by the way knowing what she now
knows she never would have signed them
senator lindsey graham with that update
also tonight panic
is set in among democrats in the media
mob we're going to analyze the latest
insane conspiracy theories all straight
ahead
first we must ask the obvious question
the media mob the democrats
they're avoiding it like the plague now
i know for a fact
privately they're scared to death about
this
what is wrong with joe biden what is
going on with joe biden
the question is this does this 77 year
old man
really have the stamina the strength the
mental acuity
mental alertness to serve in the
toughest most demanding job
on earth now in 1984 well similar
questions were posed to
73 year old president ronald reagan that
was during his reelection campaign
and here's how reagan famously responded
i will not make age an issue of this
campaign
i am not going to exploit for political
purposes
my opponents youth and inexperience
that race ended right there 49 state
sweep by ronald reagan
we saw a much different response from
joe biden here's his response
well again we see it often completely
incoherent it's actually a little hard
to watch
actually you know like barking at a
reporter it's not the first time he's
done this
he loses his train of thought he became
totally completely
utterly confused again fairly common
occurrence with uh
joe take a look but please clarify
specifically have you taken a cognitive
no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president
trump who brags about his test
and makes your mental state an issue for
voters
well if he can't figure out the
difference between an elephant and a
lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
but i mean i'm so forward looking to
have
an opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
there could be plenty of time
and by the way as i joke with them you
know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental fil
my physical as well as my mental fitness
and uh to uh you know to make a judgment
about
who i am
come on man a cocaine test are you a
junkie
an elephant and a lion what did we just
watch
this is just simply not normal or
appropriate
behavior and apparently biden even
forgot that just a few weeks ago
remember
it was actually telling reporters and
the american people that he was
constantly tested for
cognitive decline occasionally of course
we'll admit everyone
gets words mixed up here there but this
is now a daily occurrence for joe biden
and joe biden this is serious as
confused as he is
he's running for the most important the
hardest the toughest the most difficult
job in the free world
he wants to be president of the united
states of america our commander-in-chief
if he's ever elected
his finger will be on that nuclear
button
so obviously mental acuity alertness
as very important and yet biden seems to
struggle
even too numerous times to list on this
show
you think i'm overstating the fact we'll
let you decide tonight take a look
four kids are just as bright and just as
talented white kids
why in god's name should someone who's
clipping coupons in the stock market
make in fact pay a lower tax rate than
someone who in fact is
uh like i said a school teacher and a
firefighter
look tomorrow's superstar tuesday and i
want to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing
joe endowed by the creator of everything
it's in the declaration of independence
and it was by the way not
super it was super tuesday not super
thursday
clipping coupons in the stock market
what does that even mean and the
confusion doesn't stop there and
i'm going to tell you even what we're
going to show you tonight
is just the small sampling we could go
on for the whole hour
take a look donald trump does pose an
excellent strength to this
the it's not hypothetical i want to be
clear i'm not going nuts all right jack
thank you very much all right it's chris
but anyways
i just did chris my son the one who
my deceased son was the attorney general
of the united states and before that
he was a federal prosecutor in one of
the largest offices in the country
the in in philadelphia a little fact
check
joe's son was never the attorney general
of the united states what is he talking
about
sadly just the tip of the iceberg here
are more
deeply troubling examples take a look
if you agree with me go to joe
303 330.
we choose truth over facts play the
radio make sure the television
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night the
the phone make sure the kids hear words
150 million
people have been killed since 2007 when
bernie voted to exempt
the gun manufacturers from liability
more than all the wars
including vietnam from that point on
carnegie on our street
truth over facts 150 million people
killed from gun violence that would be
almost half the country
tonight it's not just the confusion the
forgetfulness the
gas that you should worry about it's
also his very
strange associated fits of rage
he just screamed at that cbs news
reporter asked him if he was a junkie
and needed a cocaine test
and this wasn't the first time that joe
imploded in front of a camera take a
look
let me she's referenced me i agreed with
the great job she did and i went on the
floor and
got you votes i got votes for that bill
i convinced people to vote for it so
let's get those things straight too
you have been no caucus no you haven't
you're a lion dog faced pony soldier you
said you were but
now you got to be honest you said i set
up my son to work in an oil company
didn't know what you said get your word
straight jack and you want to check
my shape on let's do push-ups together
here man let's do let's run let's do
whatever you want to do
[Music]
these are the types of things terry
mcauliffe was referring to when he said
i'm perfectly fine if joe biden stays in
his
basement bunker until election day he
always sees two people a day
all right let's state some facts joe
biden loses his trend of thought
often he mixes numbers up often he
struggles to remember
certain words at times he doesn't even
know what day of the week it is what
state he's in and what office he's even
running for
he's experiencing free frequent bouts of
irritability
anger confusion i'm not a doctor i don't
know what's going on with biden
but it's obvious that something is off
very off and even though he barely
leaves his basement bunker he looks
exhausted kind of looks like he needs a
hot cocoa and a little nappy every day
now given what we see wouldn't it be a
good idea for him to
take that cognitive test by the way
double a comprehensive
physical exam share the results with the
american people president trump has
already done
that and more it's an honest question at
this point and before early voting
starts
we the american people deserve an answer
recently for the president encouraged
biden to take the test
when he sat down with an interview with
dr siegel from the medical aid team take
a look
joe should take that test because
something's going on and and i say this
with respect
i mean it's gonna probably happen to all
of us
right you know it's gonna happen we have
to have somebody that's sharp
if this person isn't sharp because i can
tell you president xi
is sharp president putin is sharp
erdogan is sharp you don't have any
non-char people that you're dealing with
and we can't have somebody that's not a
100 percent